welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's watched
the mcu
14 million and 605 times it was a long
lock down yeah
don't judge me now because of this i
have noticed some pretty cool easter
eggs in doctor strange
that not only tied back to one division
but also the rest of the mcu
and what we've seen so far of loki
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down some of the best easter
eggs in the movie
as well as some hidden details that
wouldn't pay off until years down the
line
now magic is becoming a big part of the
mcu and we're slowly learning more and
more about it
however what you may not have noticed is
that there are colors associated with
each type
that we see the sorcerers using
throughout the marvel universe
typically magic is shown to be orange
however in the case of chaos magic
it shines as bright red juxtaposing this
which i sound pretty pretentious saying
dark magic typically presents as purple
throughout one division we watch as this
color manifests whenever agathic has to
spell
and it becomes clear that this is the
color that's always going to be
associated with darkness
when we meet door mammo at the end of
doctor strange we can also see that he
basks in flashes of it too
therefore i think purple magic will also
come with dark wizardry
and as always it's all connected
now when agatha is held in place at her
trial in salem we can see that the
witches cast blue magic on her
blue magic and because of this the
colors that represent certain magics
could be related to the infinity stones
red magic may represent the reality
stone as it's always in a state of flux
purple for power and blue for the space
stone as people can be held in place
with it
when loki went to stab thanos in
infinity war you could catch the mad
titan holding back the blade with the
space stone
which showed us being blue so it could
all be linked
or it could be a reach and here's why in
episode 2 of loki we come face to face
with lady lucky
and she uses green magic to possess
people this color is typically
associated with the time stone
and maybe it means she's having the time
of her life
possessing people or maybe we should
just jump onto something else before we
ruin the entire video
saying that though the film does end
with strange creating a time loop with
the time stones which spawn forth green
magic
so maybe the possession is just linking
in with the color of loki
which typically tends to be green
interestingly mysterio had green magic
too
and though he was probably unaware of
the spells cast by loki
i like that this color is always
associated with tricking or fooling
someone
but you can't fool me and i know that
mephisto
is behind it all you're not gonna fool
me now the time stone is a very
important mcguffin in doctor strange
and it allows him to not only manipulate
time but also see into the future
in infinity war we learn that he views
14 million and 605 outcomes of the
battle with thanos
and this is actually a nod to the
fantastic four issue 605
in which the team built a machine that
allowed them to see into the future
mordo warns strange that messing with
time can create paradoxes
time loops and alternate realities and
one thing that has become apparent
loki is that if you mess with things
beyond one timeline then the tva will
always come and stop you
so how exactly was strange able to see
14 million different outcomes
if there should only be one well
potentially strange did see several
branching
pathways but as the avengers never
physically went down these paths
no nexus events were created so the tva
didn't have to intervene
strange clearly says there is only one
outcome in which they win
and we know from episode 1 of loki that
this was always meant to happen
so he was in fact seeing the one sacred
timeline the way strange is sitting
also looks like there's a time stream
across the middle of him
and this is a bit similar to when the
timekeepers were holding up the sacred
timeline in the animated video and the
movie starts off with kaiselia stealing
a book from the ancient ones collection
these books are glowing almost as if
they're alive and when we see the dark
hold in agatha's basement
it too is bursting with light beneath
the cover wander ends up taking this
and in the post-credits scene of episode
9 we can see that she's reading it
whilst
also walking around her little trunk
will get away
this shows that she's superior to
strange in strength as when he was
reading books on the astral plane
he had to do it as he slept because he
didn't have the energy to do two things
at the same time
men in there multitasking in the
multiverse eh am i right ladies
later on when strange visits the library
we can't see that a book is missing from
the ancient one's collection
and this could actually be where the
darkhold was every time i brought this
up i've had someone go
uh well actually caissilius took that
but in the opening of the movie air all
he does is rip out of the pages that he
needs
and he dumps the book on the floor you
idiot now strange steals this book from
the library
and he uses the time stone to bring the
pages back
thus this missing book being out in the
world does hint towards the darkholds
appearance in one division
kaiselius and cole head off and they're
chased by the ancient one
we later learned that she pulls from the
dark dimension and a symbol appears on
her forehead in order to show this
in the opening of the movie the ancient
one wears a hood so that no one can see
this as being cast
and this is why kaiselius calls her a
hypocrite
also is it just me or is something
always up with mads mikkelsen's eyes in
every movie that he said
she'll get those checked out you [ __ ]
now the first look at
i'm sorry for corny that you're a nice
guy now the first look at strange that
we get is a close-up of his hands
and this brings attention to how much he
values them strange is very egotistical
because of what he can do with them
and thus focusing on them here makes it
even more devastating when they're
destroyed
no thumbs downing my videos for you now
if you're enjoying the video
then i'd massively appreciate the thumbs
up and if you're a marvel maniac like me
then don't forget to subscribe as we do
videos like this each and every day
anyway when strangers pulled into the
multiverse we can see that hands haunt
him in every part of the environment
and there's even some trippy visuals of
hands growing out of hands
strange's hands being damaged are a
consistent thing throughout the mcu
and even an endgame when he holds up one
finger to tony we can see it shaking
slightly
due to the nerve damage that he received
now whilst they are typically shown to
evoke negative emotions
there is some symbolic hope that shines
through later on in the movie just
before the ancient one dies
she holds strange's hand and this shows
that he is somewhat accepting of the ark
he's been
on from here we could to him washing his
hands once more
mirroring the first scene and again it's
like poetry they rhyme
now the time stone is of course a very
important object in the movie
and this focus on time is actually
foreshadowed at several points
when strange is carrying out an
operation he gets someone to cover their
watch
and when he visits his home he opens a
drawer with several spinning watches
inside
these spin much like how the eye of
agamotto spins open
and we can see that there's a green
light on all of them which is of course
a nod to the infinity stone
strange chooses a watch and this ends up
breaking however rather than throwing it
away
he keeps it with him at all times the
movie actually ends with him putting on
the watch
and then looking at it this sort of
reflects how he has himself been broken
but he's still ready to face things and
find a purpose
hilariously when he first puts on the
watch we can see that the date is
february 2nd
which you might also know as groundhog
day because this watch breaks it gets
stuck on that date
and the groundhog day movie was about a
time loop which
foreshadows the end of this film and how
strange defeats dormammu
just before his car crash strange is
told of several patients that may or may
not be a nod to other characters in the
mcu
there's a tenuous one of an air force
colonel with a broken back that may be
roadie
though it could also be the guy who got
his spine twisted in justin hammer's
demonstration in iron man 2.
there's also one that many people
thought was captain marvel but we know
from her origin
story that this isn't the case
interestingly though there is a 68 year
old woman brought
up but strange refuses to work on her
because she's elderly
thus meaning she's more likely to die in
surgery and this would mess up his
perfect record
strange later operates on the ancient
one a very elderly woman
and she dies so this conversation kind
of foreshadows him losing his perfect
record
but the fact that he was still willing
to help someone shows how much he's
grown as a character
after the crash strange goes to a man
who is mystically mended
played by benjamin bratt we catch him
playing basketball
and every time i watch this scene i
think back to when he played basketball
against halle berry
in another comic book classic catwoman
leave a comment down below if you want
me to break down catwoman
it's gonna be a best breakdown anyone's
ever done the best best breakdown of all
time
now strange goes to meet the ancient one
and she gives him a cup of tea
later in the post-credits scene thor
goes to the sanctum sanctorum
and before he's given a beer we can see
him drinking from the same cup
the ancient one tells him to open his
eye and shout eric the boss boss from
new rock stars for pointing out that she
touches what is typically thought to be
someone's third eye
might also foreshadow how strange has to
open the eye of agamotto in order to win
and that's my contribution to that
easter egg thread
now strange goes on a trippy journey it
feels like what happens
when you have a couple of drinks and
look at yourself in the mirror you'll
understand when you're older kids and
in space he comes across a butterfly
symbolically
butterflies show rebirth and transition
which strange is of course going through
at this moment
strange settles in quickly and is given
the wifi password shambhala
and this word in tibet means
enlightenment however the doctor strange
graphic novel into shambhala
also deals with the ancient one's death
which of course happens later on in the
movie
now it's not too long before he becomes
one of the ancient one's best students
but kai selius has other plans a one
point strange traps one of his zealots
in what i think is the sahara desert
and later when cassilius goes to hong
kong we can see he came from the desert
because he had to go and get his crew
he chases strange and moro through the
city and we get a cameo by stan lee
now you might not have noticed but he's
actually reading the doors of perception
by aldous huxley this is a pretty trippy
book that goes in depth on psychedelic
drugs
and it actually helped to inspire a lot
of things in the doctor strange comics
the ancient one arrives to help out and
we can see that she makes a platform
with the triquetra in the middle of it
this symbol is something that's appeared
in the thor films at several points
and it represents several things in
nordic mythology including the father
son and holy spirit
as well as the knot of time in thor
ragnarok just before strange sends loki
and thought of their father
he also makes one showing that it's
connected to them and as always
it's all connected now kaiselius beats
the ancient one and on the astral plane
she says that she wasn't able to see
past her death
in infinity war however strange was able
to see into the timeline where the
avengers lost
and also the one where they won because
in those other potential pathways
he either didn't hand over the time
stone and let tony die
or he was brought back by the snap thus
because the character never actually
died he was able to see past getting
dusted
whereas the ancient one is unable to see
beyond this
kaiselius launches his attack and we
discover that the three sanctums are
located in hong kong
london and new york interestingly these
are the first three places that kill
manga targets when launching his attack
at the end of black panther
strange ends up flying to the portal to
take dormammu on face to face
and this could be a nod to how iron man
flew through one at the end of the
avengers
in order to take down the chittari scott
derrickson the director
actually said far too many movies and
with the heroes attempting to close
portals
so he wanted to show someone who would
fly into danger instead of shutting it
off
dormammu is actually voiced by benedict
cumberbatch and this is because the
creature existed in a world without any
real life
so it mimicked the first thing that it
came across doctor strange wins and he
won the hearts of millions
including my grandma who said he's her
favorite marvel character
officially now obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the film
and what's happening in loki right now
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of june in which we're
giving away three copies of the phase 3
mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the video the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
we've got a marvel related video on
screen right now
and i tell you you better go head over
there or else and you better
click the like otherwise have a bloody
kickoff anyway
he's still here yeah because you can
hear me talking but thanks for watching
until the end of the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace